jetzt schauen wir mal was mein kollege
aus der politik ralf schuler sagt du
kommst ja direkt aus dem bundestag ganz
frisch ist studio hierher solar hat die
bombe platzen lassen sagte ja ich will
kanzlerkandidat werden konnte man damit
rechnen dass er ist will das war seit
langem bekannt aber wie er es will das
waren noch nicht ganz klar also wir
zuerst einen typen wie kann man es
inszenieren so dass es nicht als eine
attacke auf verlassen wirkt und das war
schon recht geschickt heute das vor
dieser fraktionsklausur zu sagen die
fraktion ist sehr stark auf seiten
söders weil viele abgeordnete fürchten
bei niedrigen umfragewerten ihren mann
dazu verlieren und außerdem war es
insofern geschickt als dass der ball von
söderling feld der cdu gespielt worden
ist die müssen jetzt sagen wen sie
wollen und angesichts der schlechten
umfragewerte von armin laschet ist das
keine ganz einfache entscheidung genau
dass uns da noch mal tiefer rein gehen
in die unterstützung was hört man so aus
den unions-kreisen wer bekommt davon wem
genau die unterstützung
das schwierige ist dass beide kandidaten
sehr unterschiedlich bewertet werden
einerseits sind die werte von armin
laschet in der tat schwierig selbst die
unionsanhänger sagen zu 58% wir trauen
ihm nicht zu dass er genügend rückhalt
für eine erfolgreiche kanzlerkandidatur
hat in der gesamtbevölkerung ist die
zahlen noch höher
andererseits gibt es aber natürlich sehr
viele gerade in den funktionärsriege der
union die sagen wir können den neuen
vorsitzenden jetzt nicht im regen stehen
lassen
er ist der vorsitzende der cdu der
größten bei der muss jetzt auch
unterstützt werden also das ist vor
allem loyalität die dafür laschet
spricht gleichwohl sieht man natürlich
dass die performance von söder dieses
druckvoller agieren dieses auftreten mit
programmatischer schärfe sehr viel
besser ankommt bei den leuten und da ist
man hin und hergerissen
das hat das stichwort performance
gegeben eine performance haben die
beiden ja auch vor wenigen stunden
dargestellt wie stuft du die rede nein
also für mich war sehr auffällig das
lasche zum beispiel recht kurz
gesprochen hat im gegensatz zur so
laschet wirkte er nervös hat mehrfach
versucht sein jackett taschen irgendwie
runter zu bügeln obwohl sie schon runden
waren er wippte leicht hin und her alles
so ein bisschen unsicher
während söder seine große stärke
ausspielte gleichzeitig zu sagen
selbstverständlich akzeptiert er jede
entscheidung selbstverständlich steht er
dann voll hinter laschet auch wenn er
also unterliegen sollte gleichzeitig
hielt er aber dann eine wahlkampfrede
die so staatsmännisch so in den themen
weit über seine zuständigkeit als
bayerischer ministerpräsident hinausging
was jeder sehen konnte
ich zeige euch jetzt mal was ihr haben
könnte den armen oder mich das war schon
ein recht raffinierter schachzug
und genau das ist es allerdings was in
der cdu manchmal eben auch opfer trost
stößt das söder so großspurig auftritt
und eben auch zeigt dass er sich für den
besseren hält meinst du dass das alles
wirklich taktik ist da jetzt auch zu
sagen also söder der der sagte ich
verstehe mich mit laschet und egal was
passiert wie es ausgeht ich werde mich
immer mit ihm verstehen ist das jetzt um
den schönen schein zu wahren
das ist natürlich einerseits ein
pflichtprogramm das ist ganz klar
also jeder jedes andere wort was man da
sagen würde wäre unpassend und würde
signalisieren dass man nicht in der zu
grossen parteien familie der union
gehört jeder der sie kennt weiß
natürlich dass er da ein gewisses
glaubwürdigkeitsproblem hat söder hat
sich so oft neu erfunden hat so oft in
seiner karriere es eben gerade nicht
dadurch geschafft sich loyal
unterzuordnen und zu warten bis er dran
ist sondern durch drängeln und es ist
schwer vorstellbar dass bei einer
kampagne die nicht so läuft wie er sich
vorstellt die möglicherweise schlechte
umfrageergebnisse für die union bringt
dass er da still in münchen sitzt und
sagt ich stärker dem arminen rücken
das ist nicht so ganz vorstellbar ganz
spannende frage was ist da halt so
hinter den kulissen passiert was
konntest du hast ja es gab natürlich am
rande dieser klausur muss man sich
vorstellen in klausur von 40 leuten in
einem riesigen saal wo sonst die
unionsfraktion tag wird 250
abstand da ist nicht viel mit kugeln und
flüstern
man muss ich schon anzurufen wenn man
was wir aber auf den gängen
da gab es dann beim geschnetzeltem zum
mittag etliche runden die beisammen
standen und sich ausgetauscht haben
wolfgang schäuble zum beispiel hat auch
gewarnt davor den streit in die fraktion
reinzutragen die fraktion ist
tatsächlich in zu großen teilen wieder
freundlich und möchte deshalb ein wort
mitreden gerne auch abstimmen darüber
das ist immer schwierig weil dann die
absturz abstimmungsergebnis der
fraktionen möglicherweise gegen das des
präsidiums steht und deshalb trat
schäuble da gewarnt aber es gab eben
auch andere runden die dann auch die
nicht einsehbaren terrasse ausgetreten
sind und sich unterhalten haben und es
gibt nach unseren informationen auch
weitere runden bis heute abend spät in
die nacht rein und es ist gut möglich
dass sich heute nacht die
kanzlerkandidatur der union klärt war ja
das wäre meine nächste frage nämlich
gewesen weil der druck das haben wir ja
auch anfangs dieser sendung schon gesagt
der ist sehr stark kommt von allen
seiten also du meinst heute nacht könnte
es schon passieren ansonsten morgen wird
es ja definitiv auch eine tagung noch
also es ist eigentlich immer der gleiche
ablauf in solchen situationen es gibt
vorher sondierungen es gibt eine
verständigung der handelnden akteure das
ist in diesem fall die cdu-spitze mit
der kanzlerin
die länderfürsten der cdu und dann wenn
man eine verständigung gefunden hat dann
geht laschet morgen möglicherweise schon
in die gremien seiner partei ins
präsidium und im vorstand und sagt wir
haben uns so und so entschieden
und dann gibt es nachmittags noch eine
präsidiumssitzung der csu
da darf man gespannt sein wenn die cdu
sagt wir stehen hinter laschet dann wird
es für die csu schwer sein
dagegenzuhalten einen kampfsituationen
mit zwei unterschiedlichen präsidien
wird man nicht machen
vermute ich also dann ist die sache
morgen abgeräumt es kann aber genauso
gut sein dass der widerstand gegen
laschet der auch in der cdu das dazu
führt dass man noch mal vertagt
grundsätzlich hast völlig recht
der druck ist da schon weil die grünen
gesagt haben in acht tagen kommen wir
mit unserem kandidaten raus bis dahin
muss die union auch etwas zu bieten
haben
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren